ha llegado el punto en que la traducción automática de voz en vivo
no solo es posible, sino que es mejor cada año.
La razón por la que les digo estas cosas
es porque me doy cuenta de que estamos llegando al punto
en el que se comenzará a plantearse una pregunta:
¿Por qué debemos aprender idiomas extranjeros
--que no sea inglés, sino uno diferente--?
¿Por qué molestarse en aprender otro cuando se está llegando al punto
en que casi todo el mundo es capaz de comunicarse en uno?
Creo que hay muchas razones,
pero primero quiero abordar
lo que probablemente hayan escuchado más,
porque en realidad es más peligroso de lo que puedan pensar.
Y esa es la idea
de que una lengua canaliza sus pensamientos,
que el vocabulario y la gramática de diferentes idiomas
da a todos un tipo diferente de viaje alucinógeno,
por así decirlo.
Esa es una idea tentadoramente maravillosa,
pero es un poco pesada.
No es del todo falsa.
Por ejemplo, en francés y español
la palabra de mesa esta, por alguna razón, marcada como femenina.
Por lo tanto, "la table", "la mesa", solo tienes que lidiar con ello.
Se ha demostrado
que si uno habla una de esas lenguas
y se nos pregunta
cómo se imaginaría una mesa hablando,
entonces con mayor frecuencia de lo que podría ser un accidente,
un franco o un hispanoparlante
dice que la mesa hablaría con una voz aguda y femenina.
Así que si Ud. es francés o español, verá a la mesa como una especie de chica,
a diferencia de si es angloparlante.
Es difícil no amar datos como estos,
y mucha gente dirá que eso significa
que hay una visión del mundo si hablan uno de esos idiomas.
Pero deben ser cuidadosos,
porque imagínese si alguien nos pone bajo el microscopio,
por nos pone digo los que hablamos inglés nativo.
¿Cuál es la visión del mundo en inglés?
Por ejemplo, tomemos un angloparlante.
Arriba en la pantalla, este es Bono.
Habla inglés.
Presumo que tiene una visión del mundo.
Ahora, este es Donald Trump.
En este orden de ideas,
él habla inglés también.
(Risas)
Y aquí la Sra. Kardashian,
y es angloparlante, también.
Así que aquí hay tres angloparlantes.
¿Qué visión del mundo tienen en común esas tres personas?
¿Qué visión del mundo está conformada a través del idioma inglés que los une?
Es un concepto muy connotado.
Paulatinamente se llega al consenso de que el lenguaje da forma al pensamiento,
pero tiende a ser más bien en oscuros aleteos psicológicos.
No es una cuestión de darle un par diferente gafas del mundo.
Ahora bien, si ese es el caso,
entonces ¿por qué aprender idiomas?
Si no va a cambiar su forma de pensar,
¿cuáles serían las otras razones?
Hay algunas.
Una de ellas es que si uno quiere empaparse de una cultura,
si quiere beber en ella, si quiere formar parte de ella,
entonces se quiera o no, el lenguaje canaliza la cultura
--y que parece dudoso--
si uno quiere empaparse de cultura,
tiene que manejar hasta cierto punto
el lenguaje en el que ocurre que se realiza esa cultura.
No hay otra manera.
Hay una interesante ilustración de esto.
Tengo que ir un poco oscuro, pero en realidad deberían buscarla.
Hay una película del director de cine canadiense Denys Arcand
--leer en inglés en la página, "Dennis Ar-cand"--,
si quieren buscarlo.
Hizo una película llamada "Jesús de Montreal".
Y muchos de los personajes
son vibrantes, divertidos, apasionados, interesantes franco-canadienses,
mujeres francoparlantes.
Hay una escena cercana al final,
donde tienen que llevar a un amigo a un hospital angloparlante.
En el hospital, tienen que hablar inglés.
Ahora, hablan inglés, pero no es su lengua materna,
prefieren no hablar en inglés.
Y hablan más despacio,
tienen acentos, no son idiomáticas.
De repente, estos personajes que se han enamorado
se convierten en cáscaras de sí mismos, son sombras de sí mismos.
Entrar en una cultura
y procesar solo la gente a través de ese tipo de cortina opaca
es no asimilar nunca de verdad la cultura.
Y así, conforme cientos de idiomas sean abandonados,
una razón para aprenderlos
es que son entradas para poder participar
en la cultura de las personas que los hablan,
simplemente en virtud del hecho de que es su código.
Esa es una razón.
Segunda razón:
se ha demostrado
que si uno habla dos idiomas, la demencia es menos probable,
y que probablemente se es un mejor multitarea.
Y estos son factores que se establecen temprano,
y por lo que debería darle algún sentido
a cuando se dan lecciones de otro idioma para niños o jóvenes.
El bilingüismo es saludable.
Y luego, tercero,
los idiomas ofrecen un montón de diversión.
Mucho más divertido que lo que se dice.
Así, por ejemplo, en árabe: "kataba" él escribió,
"Yaktubu", él escribe, ella escribe.
"Uktub," escribir, en el imperativo.
¿Qué tienen esas cosas tienen en común?
Todas esas cosas tienen en común
las consonantes que se sientan en el medio como pilares.
Se quedan quietas,
y los vocales bailan alrededor de las consonantes.
¿Quién no querría rodarlas en torno a su boca?
Lo verá en el hebreo,
lo verá en el lenguaje principal de Etiopía, el amárico.
Eso es gracioso.
O las lenguas que tienen diferentes órdenes de palabras.
Aprender con diferente orden de las palabras
es como conducir en diferentes lados de una calle si vas a cierto país,
o la sensación que se tiene cuando se pone hamamelis alrededor de los ojos
y se siente el cosquilleo.
Una lengua puede provocar eso.
Así, por ejemplo,
"El gato en el sombrero vuelve de nuevo",
un libro que estoy seguro que todos vemos a menudo,
así como "Moby Dick".
Una frase es, "¿Sabe dónde lo encontré?
¿Sabe dónde estaba? Estaba comiendo pastel en la bañera,
¡Sí, era él!".
Bien. Ahora, si lo aprende en chino mandarín,
entonces tiene que dominar,
"¿Usted puede saberlo, ¿yo supe donde lo encontré?
Él estaba en la bañera hartándose de torta,
¡No hay error mascando"!
Eso se siente bien.
Imagine que es capaz de hacer eso a la vez durante años y años.
O, ¿han aprendido algo de camboyano?
Yo tampoco, pero si lo hiciera,
me gustaría llegar a rodar en mi boca no una docena de vocales horneadas
como tiene el inglés,
sino unas 30 vocales diferentes
rumiándolas y soltándolas por boca camboyana
como abejas en una colmena.
Eso es lo que se puede obtener de una lengua.
Y más al punto, vivimos en una épóca
en la que es más fácil que nunca aprender por propia cuenta otro idioma.
Antes tocaba ir a un salón de clase,
y habría algún maestro diligente,
algún maestro genio allí,
pero estaba allí solamente en ciertos momentos
y entonces tenía que ir,
y entonces no era muchas veces.
Había que ir a clase.
Si no era eso, que tenía algo llamado disco.
Yo adquirí experiencia en ellos.
Solo que había tal cantidad de datos en un disco,
o un casete,
o incluso que objeto antiguo conocido como CD.
Aparte de eso tenías libros que no funcionaban,
de la forma en que estaban.
Hoy en día se puede tumbar
--tumbar en el piso de su sala--
bebiendo wiski
y aprender solo cualquier idioma que desee
con conjuntos maravillosos como piedras Roseta.
Lo recomiendo encarecidamente el menos conocido Glossika también.
En cualquier momento,
se puede hacer más y mejor.
Uds. mismos pueden darse sus placeres de la mañana en varios idiomas.
Tomen algo de "Dilbert" en varios idiomas cada mañana;
pueden aumentar sus habilidades.
No podría haberlo hecho hace 20 años
cuando la idea de tener cualquier idioma que quería
en su bolsillo,
procedente de su teléfono,
habría sonado a ciencia ficción a la gente muy sofisticada.
Así que recomiendo
que aprendan idiomas distintos al que estoy hablando,
porque nunca ha habido un mejor momento para hacerlo.
Es un montón de diversión.
No va a cambiar su forma de pensar,
pero con toda seguridad, impulsará su forma de pensar.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)